hey this is presh talwalkar and you're
watching mind your decisions
here's a fun little magic trick you can
perform anytime you're at the bookstore
the library or anywhere that has book
barcodes
let's say you ask someone to pick out
any book in the store and they bring
harry potter and the sorcerer's stone
now on the back side of the book is a
bar code
tell them to locate a 13-digit number
that starts with the numbers 9 7 and 8.
this is the isbn 13 code now the numbers
look pretty random
but in fact there's a secret
mathematical code hidden in these
numbers
the code is at the very last digit the
13th digit is known as a check digit and
it's determined by the other 12 numbers
the check digit helps detect errors if
the barcode has been damaged or the
number has been entered incorrectly so
we're going to take these first 12
numbers and color code them alternately
the first thing we'll do is we'll add up
every other number starting with the
first number on the left
so we add 9 8 three eight nine and one
this will give a sum of thirty eight
we then take the sum of all of the other
digits here colored in green
and then we multiply that sum by three
this will give a result of seventy eight
now we add up these two results and we
get one hundred and sixteen
to get the check digit we answer the
following question
what number do you need to add to get to
a multiple of 10
so what positive number will bring 116
up to a multiple of 10.
well 120 is a multiple of 10 so we need
to add 4 to 116.
therefore 4 is the check digit and in
fact that's the very last digit of this
barcode
now let's do another example with
everyone's favorite book the joy of game
theory
so i've already blocked out the 13th
digit let's see if we can calculate what
it is
so we first add up all of the black
digits
we then add up all of the green digits
we take that sum and multiply it by
three
we then add these two results together
and we get one hundred and four
now what positive number do we need to
add to get to a multiple of ten
well if we add six to 104 we'll get to
110
so 6 is going to be our check digit
and in fact 6 is the last digit of this
barcode
so it's a neat little trick that you can
calculate the last digit from the other
12 and it'll be a surprise to many
people because they don't realize that
the last digit is calculated from the
other 12.
now for those curious here's a general
mathematical calculation of the check
digit
you can use it to calculate the last
digit of any isbn 13 code
now let's say someone brings you a book
that was published a long time ago like
the elements of style and it doesn't
have a 13 digit number it'll probably
have a 10 digit number like the
following
this is the older isbn 10 code
and there is a similar check digit
process for that
it's much more complicated but let me
just explain how it works you can
calculate the tenth digit from the other
nine
so you're going to take the first digit
and multiply it by ten
you take the second digit multiply it by
nine and you take the third digit
multiply it by eight and so on where you
have decreasing weights over each of the
following digits
so this is much more complicated to
solve especially using mental math but
let's say you have a calculator and
you're able to calculate these sums
you then need to add up all of these
numbers and then you need to ask the
question
what single digit number do you need to
add to get to a multiple of 11
well for 111 we actually need to add 10
to get to 121 so that's not a single
digit
but in isbn 10 what you do is if you get
10 you use the single digit of x as a
roman numeral because x is equal to 10
as a roman numeral so here x is the
check digit in an isbn 10 code
but if you got a single digit from zero
to nine you would just use that single
digit of zero to nine
so here's the general process to finding
the check digit in the isbn 10 code you
take the weighted sum of each digit and
then you calculate the following
if you get a number of 10 you need to
use x otherwise use the single digits
going from 0 to nine
so it's a fun little trick that you can
calculate the last digit in the barcode
from the other digits
thanks for watching these math videos
available for free on youtube build
confidence for students and inspire
mathematical discovery for viewers
around the world they have over 100
million views and the channel now has
over 1 million subscribers
please subscribe for free to get the
newest videos and email me a puzzle or
topic presh
mindyourdecisions.com you can grab a mug
or t-shirt
or you can check out my books both of
these links are listed in the video
description you can also support me on
patreon for exclusive rewards thanks for
watching and thanks for your support